during that last break I get tapped on
the shoulder that the boss wants to call
in now everyone put put away your stuff
you know let's move the strippers out of
here Oh dan are you there
dan hey red oh hey red how are you hey
um how you doing big man
doing great the chair it feels a little
intimidating obviously I had to raise
the chair up a little bit you know
someone small was sitting in it but I
had kind of raised it up in the
microphone but things are going well
here in the studio you wanted me to let
the Danette talk a little bit more I
kind of nixed that they're talking less
is that okay with you yeah I'm sure I'll
hear about it after the show from them
but go ahead it's your show if you're
three hours have fun with them I got a
question for you this is the poll
question we had two of them but I want
you to weigh in on this one because
actually this is you know it was all
audience participation here so we let
the Danette answer this was more
directed towards them in our prime Larry
Bird's 27 I'm 27 one three-point
competition man against man who would
you pick you again ended up - - I was
the tiebreaker I'm just letting you know
the results was - two out of the DNS and
I had to be the tiebreaker but I'm
asking you in Oprah the fact that you
the fact that you were like waiting this
long
I like that cuz I thought for sure you
two came straight out and said the
legend well I would I would probably
take him narrowly because I saw you too
many times hit big shots and not afraid
to get a big shot and you have to have
that
whatever that is in you that you want
the ball in a big moment and to even go
on the floor with bird in a competition
like that so I would take Larry but I
would take it begrudgingly because the
history shows that you were you're in
the top five greatest three-point
shooters of all time
that's Larry legend Larry legend walking
off with his finger in the air and the
three-point competition walking in the
locker room saying who's playing for
second right Dan how is the Lilly King
story playing down there in Brazil
I loved her post swim interview with
Michele Tafoya is she a new American
icon in 19 years old well I like what
she did that she put up - shut up
somebody else and when you're gonna say
to this Russian swimmer who had been
suspended before for doping and she said
look I'm a good clean way and this and
I'm taking home the gold medal so it you
don't normally see that it feels like
it's a fraternity and it's in a lot of
these sports but they they see each
other all the time she was having none
of that and waving her finger right back
at her and you know it's back to the
Cold War there I just thought it was it
was something a little bit different
than you would normally see it in that
sport was there any interaction between
the two on the stand afterwards or no no
handshake no hug I didn't see no I
didn't see it but but they played nice
up there because she everybody had a
smile on when you have a medal around
your neck you have a smile on but I
don't know what it was before that or
right after that but in that moment for
the picture they played nice who wins
tonight between Michael Phelps and Chad
Lowe close obviously there's another
rivalry that's going on here him
shadowboxing in front of the greatest
Olympic swimmer of all time and then
staring him down before they both got on
the blocks who takes it tonight
obviously Chad Lowe close lon in London
we've got the rematch here in Rio who do
you like well I liked Phelps because
this is part of the
reason why he came back he had
unfinished business so he has a chance
to finish that business tonight and he's
just a different guy the way he his
personality his demeanor he's different
he's not as stressed he got the baby the
fiancee he's enjoying it he's enjoying
being sort of the senior leader of the
whole team and I just think he's he said
he swam in London and he wasn't even in
shape he wasn't even prepared he said
there was just pure talent that got me
through I think he dedicated himself to
go out in style
so I I expect him to win well I
appreciate you calling in and and
checking on us v Dan asked because I do
consider myself v Dan ed I hope not only
myself but we're making you proud while
you're you know paying the bills down
there in Rio where we're holding the
fort down here in LA so I hope we're
making you proud boss thank you for
doing it reg you you and charissa and
everybody else this week and you know it
means a lot I appreciate it and I'll
talk to you guys tomorrow all right
citronella candle spray a lot on you
make sure everything is okay all right
what we want you to come back okay all
right that's Dan Patrick the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience